let's build on our previous
understanding of morphemes and word
classes as we move on to the particle
this class is in some ways a catch-all
category it includes a lot of little
words that have some real function but
not a lot of content meaning they
include conjunctions
they include interjections like look
that express more emotional content than
semantic content they also included type
of word that's a little bit trickier to
handle many languages use small
grammatical words that sit next to the
word they relate to an example would be
a preposition in English what we know as
prepositions usually describe some
spatial or temporal relation like above
the table below the table beside the
table these are all prepositions the
name actually doesn't come from anything
to do with their meaning it comes from
the fact that they have to sit right
before pre then noun that they are
placed next to pose any type of
grammatical word that works this way is
known as in AD position the name ad
position just relates that the word is
placed next to another word a
preposition is placed before a post
position is placed afterwards I've
already mentioned a few prepositions in
English but prepositions don't have to
mark space or time relative to someone
or something in other languages in
Hawaiian for instance prepositions
Marcos subject the preposition all marks
a subject whereas the preposition e
marks an object here are two examples
here we see an example of a language
using prepositions to mark a grammatical
feature we've talked about before so
keep your eyes open for languages that
do this that use ad positions rather
than say inflectional affixes in
Japanese the subject marker got and the
object marker will appear after the
words that they mark as subject and
object so they seem to work like post
positions at first glance and in both
the Hawaiian and Japanese examples we
have particles that play the role of
marking case for nouns
another group of words sometimes classed
as a type of particle is the article
articles include indefinite articles
like a or an in English and the definite
article V in English the classification
is tricky because articles may exhibit
many of the properties of adjectives as
well this very quick overview of
particles just introduced the concept
but keep particles in mind as you move
on to the next lesson where we'll start
putting together all the classes of
words we've met so far
you